with great power comes great
responsibility
my content existed because I tried my
very hardest to be an absolute not a
realist especially with uncomfortable
truths I was pointing out that very
uncomfortable is that a truth it's an
uncomfortable truth in many parts of the
world it's not a truth that I'm happy
about I don't want to be seen as a
negative influence in the world I know
that there's a whole bunch of men I get
thousands of emails a week from men
whose lives I've saved I get thousands
of emails a week from men who are on the
verge of suicide and I've saved their
lives
I believe in protecting and providing
I've been misunderstood I don't want
anybody to be offended by anything I say
I want to be a positive force in the
world I don't want anybody to hear what
I say and make them feel bad about
themselves I want all people to live
righteous and good whether they're male
or female I think righteous is living
true to your heart and knowing that
you're doing good by people not snaking
anybody not lying to anybody I know I
live a very righteous life the
government's not capable of helping the
poor and this is why it's so important
as a person you take personal
responsibility and understand you're
living in a world where the Matrix can
be cracked you can make a bunch of money
but you need to take responsibility and
do it I refuse to accept that there are
people out there who cannot become happy
contented individuals I refuse to accept
we live in a world where God has created
people who no matter how hard they work
and how good their life becomes can't be
happy I don't accept that I accept that
the universe is a very giving place and
that God loves all of us and if you try
your best and you work hard you can
become a better person I'm telling the
younger generation that if they don't
get up and work hard and make sure that
they're important that the world's not
going to get bit about them 99 of my
content was aimed at man telling the
truth saying that as a man you're born
with no inherent value you have to
become important you have to go through
some pain or go through some suffering
to make people care about you otherwise
you're not going to matter as a dude if
you walk into the party and you've put
no effort into your life nobody nobody
about you and every man out here knows
and one of the great things about the
masculine journey and masculinity is
that we've all lived a semi-similar
story it's kind of cool like we've all
been the teenager gets heartbroken we've
all been unimportant we've all like
worked hard and then started to get some
clout and then we've all kind of lived
the same kind of Journey so I say to
everybody out there yeah if you don't
follow that path and follow that journey
in one way or another get to the top
whether it's fighting whether it's
comedy whether it's musician whatever it
is
if you're just going to stay somewhere
near the bottom and then at the age of
44 you know email me saying I'm
depressed well of course you're
depressed Loser yeah but that was your
choice because you
to build yourself as a man and if you
decide not to build yourself then then
your life's gonna suck
[Music]
my main message is to resist a slave
mind uh to understand that every single
thing you're being told has an agenda
behind it where you would be told
otherwise to examine every strongly held
belief you have and try and identify
where it comes from and why you have it
I sit and argue with people I discuss
things with people and they so fervently
believe a point and I say why do you
believe that so much like do you have
personal experience no but I saw the
news the news told you X and now you are
desperate you will sit here for hours
arguing that point
a lot of people are completely empty
vessels ready to be programmed and I try
and tell people listen to just stop for
a second and understand that
the things they're telling you to
believe are not necessarily for your
benefit
the people who make the rules don't make
the rules for the benefit of everybody
they make the rules for the benefit of
the people who make the rules of the
game so um telling people to resist to
slave mind and just be critically
critical thinkers keep their brain open
pay attention to things be perspicacious
that's the general theme and it doesn't
matter whether you're left right liberal
man woman Etc just think for yourself
that's the general message I believe men
and women are a beautiful Union I think
we're slightly different but when we
work together we're the most powerful
force in the world and I certainly
believe that men and women when they
work together is the most beautiful
force on the planet so of course I
believe in men and women of course I
believe in love of course I believe in
marriage of course I believe in family I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect the
woman and provide for her so he needs to
make sure that she's safe he needs a
degree of authority I believe women are
sovereign individuals and they can make
any choice they so desire I think that
it's important that we remember that a
man has a duty I think I certainly in my
relationship have a financial
responsibility to provide for my woman
my woman would never have to work unless
she wanted to because I'm the kind of
person who works hard enough and I'll
make another point that needs to be said
the number of women who have stood up
and stuck up for me is ignored thousands
of women are making videos saying I've
been entertain such a nice guy I wish I
had a man like Andrew Tate who felt
responsible to protect and provide for
me you know what I I do belong to my
husband that's why I married him and I
love him we ignore the thousands of
women who stood up and prepared and and
stood by me and said everything I said
is true this is that there's a large
contingent of men who still want to make
money go to the gym be strong drive a
fast car be traditionally masculine and
don't want to be shamed for that
I believe that feeling depressed is real
I don't believe depression as a clinical
disease is real enough I think PTSD is
very real I've unfortunately I have some
friends who suffer from that and I know
that feeling depressed is real I believe
that the number one power you have
against these things are taking trying
to take control of your own mind and
affecting your own life I believe that
it's not healthy to hand over all your
power and believe that depression is an
outside disease that you can't affect I
know that when I've had difficult
periods in my life and also many of my
friends like I've said suffer from PTSD
and been through terrible things I've
lived a very difficult life and I know
people who have that the things that
made them feel better is when they woke
up and said you know what I'm not going
to allow this to damage me anymore I'm
going to take responsibility I'm going
to get up and I'm going to fight this as
hard as I can
if someone comes to me and says I'm
clinically depressed or I feel very very
sad I would say the first thing you need
to do is stop accepting the identity of
a clinically depressed person stop
accepting you have no control over this
and what you need to do is stop
identifying that way and let's work
together to try and fight against a lot
of people who are clinically depressed
are suffering with something in their
life and if you fix the problem in their
life perhaps they won't feel depressed
the thousands of people who have emailed
me saying my doctor told me I was
clinically depressed and it's a disease
that I have got in my brain and I can't
be fixed and I started listening to you
and I realized that that's not the case
and I can fix my own life and you're the
only person who has ever helped me I
believe feeling depressed is real I do
not believe it's a disease that you
catch from the sky and you cannot affect
I believe that no matter what happens I
believe you have control of your own
mind and you can fight against it I
believe if you change your circumstances
in your life you may feel different I'll
give you a quick example I had a guy who
emailed me saying it was clinically
depressed and was going to kill himself
I obviously am not a psychiatrist I'm
not a doctor I told him because I reply
to my emails I said have you been to a
psychiatrist he said yes I'm clinically
depressed I've been on these pills this
amount of time I'm on antidepressants
doesn't work I said I don't know what to
say to besides this and he said he lost
his girlfriend that's why I became
clinically depressed I said listen go to
the gym get a six-pack first once you've
got a six-pack email me again
still feel like killing yourself I don't
know what else to say to you but I'd say
strong body is a strong mind GO train
he went he starts sending me progress
pictures emailing me him getting better
better shape and eventually got six-pack
he's not a professional bodybuilder and
he said I can't believe I was
considering that I feel so much better
Etc the doctor was telling him he was
clinically depressed and couldn't cure
it he started taking control of his own
life and now he felt better that if
somebody has depression of any kind
whether it's clinical whether it exists
or not whether they feel depressed or
not whatever they're taking control of
their life taking personal
responsibility and working hard is
always going to be the positive best
thing they can possibly do for their
life going forward
of course money can't buy happiness I
agree but money is the third most
important thing in the world first is
your relation versus your health because
you have nothing you're going to die
second is your relationships because you
need love and family that matters the
most but money can buy everything else
so money's the third most important
thing the average people come to me and
say what do I do I'm just the average
guy and my only answer is stop being the
average guy
it's my only answer you can't just be
the average guy anymore the I the idea
from the 1950s that you can just be the
normal average law-abiding hard-working
Citizen and you'll have a good life is
gone any man out here who goes I'm just
going to work hard do my bit and obey
the laws and I'll have a good life no
you won't no you will not just doing
your job is never going to make you rich
because you're just gonna be taxed into
infinity and you're gonna stay broke so
just obeying laws and doing your job now
has set you up for to be a peon and a
slave for attorney you have to get
yourself in a position where you're
making enough money
you don't know what to talk about then
you don't understand money so go learn
how money Works go learn how Bank Works
go sell on YouTube for free you don't
just pay 50 Grand in four years at the
University go sit on YouTube and
understand money banking or the real
estate market any of it understand the
last housing price crash why it happened
understand mortgage rates and how this
affected by interest rates understand it
and then go sit with someone else who
understands it and talk about it people
should even if they haven't got a penny
in the world should be going to these
meetings about real estate about
investing that especially if it's cheap
they should go just meet other people
who at least have money have
conversations about money talk about it
how are you going to get what you don't
talk about and yes the cycle of
precipitation right so a cloud comes it
rains it falls down to the ground it
goes underwater under the ground
whatever goes into a stream it moves
into the stream goes to the ocean
evaporates again up to a cloud floats
somewhere else falls down again it's
always moving that's how money is people
think that money is in these large
stagnant pools hidden hidden in people's
bank accounts it's not really group
money is constantly moving all the time
and if you can find a way to get in
between it and stand in the right place
at the right time you're gonna get wet I
think that's the new modern way to view
the world it's an attention economy it
doesn't matter what you do if you're
getting attention you'll make money one
habit that people need to adopt and this
is a habit I had for a very long time
and I've actually recently cleared it
from my brain because I've reached a
point where peace of mind is worth more
than money but every single time money
is spent you need to identify
how your money was taken from you and I
say taken because money can't be made
money is taken because the only people
who can make money in the government so
if you're a government you can make
money you can print it from thin air or
a bank but if you're a person you're not
making money you're convincing other
people to give it to you you're taking
money from others so every single time
you spend money on anything you need to
identify how it was taken from you when
you go and buy a coffee don't just go
buy the coffee and sit down sit and say
why did I buy this coffee okay I really
want coffee yeah but then why did I go
into this store and not that store is it
better advertising does it have less of
a line do they have seeing how did they
convince me to come in here how much did
this coffee cost six quid what's the
profit margin on that probably five
pound fifty five pounds the AE probably
by the time the cup probably costs more
than the coffee the coffee's just water
how did they convince me to spend six
pounds in this place when you sit there
and analyze and you all start to learn
little lessons about business you'll
learn about the importance of the
signage you learn about the importance
of there being no cue yeah so that if
you ever run a business I say with my
business my people all the time faster
all the time quicker yeah like I have a
couple businesses that are physical I'm
like I don't want to see a line I don't
want to see empty because it looks bad
so when there's lines you work fast
we're down to one or two people you take
your time you talk to the customer keep
it so there's like always one person
like manage the line like people don't
think about this stuff no one's gonna
sit and wait and lock you maybe some
idiots will but people like me won't
we've got [ __ ] to do right my time's
worth money I'm not gonna stand wait in
line so you have to identify how your
money is taken from you if you start
doing that with every single time you
spend anything ever you're going to
start to identify business opportunities
and you're going to sit there and you're
gonna have coffee and you're gonna go
you know what
they could have sold cake and they
didn't
could I out-compete this place let's
imagine I had the money to start coffee
shop right next door how would I out
compete them well I'd have cake because
they don't have cake also most people in
here are businessmen and this the guy
serving some dude no we need a cute
waitress his ass is fired we need a
chick put a chick here put some cake in
uh Financial Times business people in
let's think people don't even think
about this stuff they don't use the
brain ever they don't ever look around
and realize how they're you spending
their money they don't look around and
look at which businesses are successful
they don't look around and pay attention
to anything they don't look at the world
and all the things are happening and how
it can benefit them none of it they
don't look at any of it they're too busy
following the circus this is why it's
clown world
I was walking to school to college with
a couple of my friends in a Ferrari
drove past
and I said bro you see that and he goes
yeah what about it I said doesn't that
piss you off
I've lost about 16. he goes why so this
dude has 400 G's for a car 400 Grand I'm
walking four miles to college because my
mom hasn't got any car he has 400 Grand
do you think he works a job do you think
he's behind a counter somewhere he knows
something about the world that I don't
know and they were like well he's Rich
I'm like yeah I know I didn't say he
wasn't Rich dummy I'm saying he knows
something about the world I don't know
and I was intrigued and it angered me I
couldn't sleep for weeks I was pissed
off every time I saw somebody with
genuine money I understood that
everything I was being told and taught
and and and they were trying to make me
believe just simply wasn't true I was
like this is none of these people are
getting these things by following the
path the system is trying to make me
follow and everybody intrinsically knows
this if you go to a if you if you're a
BP you're at Petrol Station and I pull
up in my Lamborghini nobody goes wow he
went to school he studied hard and they
do that because they know that the mo
the easiest way to get amass wealth is
to break the rules because the rules are
not designed to allow most people most
people to make money you can make money
within the rules of course you can but
most people don't most people who follow
the path work consume die that's it so I
always do the same thing as you and I
knew there had to be another way I knew
that just working for money was a
paradigm that that wasn't true and then
you understand making your money work
for you and you understand delinking
your time for money you start learning
to understand these things but
eventually you build a system
and you build an ecosystem like me I
have 60 or 70 people work from for me
all around the world and things just
happen and money just kind of appears as
long as everything's well organized
I mean in my experience like imagine if
I had didn't have all this money and I
had to go get a job again I'd get a
sales job because I've always been a
Salesman and uh I I think that's a very
important life skill to have to be good
at sales and to deal with the stress and
have a commission only environment but
they don't even I don't know if they
even teach sales in University yeah it's
all garbage you know they don't teach
anything important they just teach
anything they teach things that are
going to keep you inside the slave mind
and they want you to go to school and
then go to college and then go to
university and get in debt and you have
to be in debt so that now you have to
work and you're working and you're in
debt and then they want you to take on
more debt if possible in the in the form
of a mortgage which a lot of people do
which we can talk about because I know
you're the property and then you're in
debt now and once you're in debt you
can't really quit your job and it's very
difficult for you to leave the country
and and now they have now they can hold
things over you that's the goal it's all
about control mechanisms and the system
is very well designed to make sure that
people are uh conditioned to obey it's
very hard for the average person to say
no to anything unless you have millions
and millions and millions of dollars
it's very difficult to even have an
opinion on subjects that's the thing
about being a man and that's what I was
saying to the kids it's like look you
need to get up and it's going to be very
very difficult the world's getting
harder and harder especially for men
it's all clout it's all status it's all
there's no way you're going to matter
unless you get up and you work extremely
hard should young men aspire to work
very hard have no criminal record become
multi-millionaires protect and provide
for the women close to them uh be
Sovereign so they can stand up and have
their own points of view in face of
cancellation be able to not be mentally
intimidated when they go on national TV
and there's traps set up for them yeah I
believe that confident strong men who
stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
the good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and if if men grow up to be like
me you're gonna have a whole bunch of
people with no criminal record dedicated
athletes who protect and provide for the
people close to them
[Music]